[Musica]
andare oltre per me significa
a cercare la luna volere la luna in
realtà vi faccio vedere una luna che
appare più volte in questo filmato mi
piace condividere oggi con voi perché
perché quando abbiamo iniziato iniziato
circa 15 anni fa con l'idea di fare un
anno sabbatico di prendermi una pausa in
una vita che era comunque per la piena
di soddisfazioni e di cose che mi
piaceva mi piaceva fare e quando ho
iniziato e abbiamo iniziato con mia
moglie con gli amici a a cercare di fare
un po la differenza cercare di fare
qualcosa di nuovo
la cosa che ci veniva ripetuta più
spesso era sì ma tu vuoi la luna
maturarono da quel momento in poi
abbiamo chiamato così la fondazione
domus de luna che la fondazione con la
quale abbiamo iniziato e portato avanti
tutti gli interventi che oggi vi
racconto brevemente e portando un po un
pezzo di questa luna per terra tra di
noi per i nostri ragazzi per i nostri
bambini
abbiamo iniziato con le comunità realtà
pensavamo di fare solamente questo di
creare una casa
erano gli anni in cui la legge stava
imponendo la chiusura degli istituti
io dico per fortuna erano strutture
molto grandi dove c'era poca famiglia
poco calore poco affetto al 31 dicembre
del 2005 gli istituti sono stati per
legge chiusi noi abbiamo fatto in modo
che ci fosse una casa
l'abbiamo chiamata casa delle stelle
dove alcuni di questi bambini potevano
essere ospitati qui vedete nelle
immagini di questi di questi bambini la
casa era una vecchia casa campidanese e
perché volevamo la luna che avevamo una
luna perché cercavamo di avere la
famiglia però nello stesso tempo
cercavamo di avere il meglio della
scienza l'approccio medico sanitario
avere terapia e pedagogia fare cose che
normalmente venivano invece distinte tu
o stavi a casa tua con la tua famiglia è
lì c'era l'abbraccio il calore oppure
venivi curato una cura amorevole mettere
insieme un po le due cose veniva
considerato così cercare la luna
dunque la luna la casa delle stelle è
aperto dal 2006 ci sono tanti tanti
bambini che sono stati accolti
abbracciati e curati all'interno di
questa casa e sono sorte poi altre case
vicino adesso stiamo vedendo casa cometa
dove insomma i bambini poi crescevano e
quindi abbiamo fatto una casa per i
grandi per i ragazzi per gli adolescenti
con la stessa logica quindi cercando di
inventare dei metodi nuovi cercando di
avere un modo di affrontare questa che è
una terribile piaga della società in
italia non solo sono 30 mila i ragazzi
che vivono fuori dalle
dalla famiglia e in sardegna sono più di
mille e raramente per loro si fa un
progetto educativo vero che traguarda
anche al al dopo con i bambini con i
ragazzi abbiamo accolto le mamme le
avete visto quindi le comunità oggi sono
comunità di bambini comunità di ragazzi
e comunità di mamme ma non ci siamo
fermati
avete visto qualche immagine dell'ex ma
l'ex me è un ex mercato abbiamo pensato
al dopo e abbiamo pensato al prima per
cercare diciamo di accompagnare i
percorsi verso un'autonomia successiva e
per cercare di prevenire laddove
possibile l'inserimento in comunità
perché comunque un tra tu puoi fare la
comunità più bella del mondo la casa più
accogliente del mondo ma comunque è un
trauma essere allontanati dalla propria
famiglia e andare a vivere in una
comunità quindi se si riesce a
intervenire prima a fare in modo che
quello che è il bisogno quello che
l'urgenza l'emergenza venga intercettata
e si si si trovi magari una soluzione
diversa rispetto a quello del rispetto
all allontanamento del tribunale meglio
ecco in questo mercato ne facciamo
musica facciamo sport facciamo arte
avete visto che tutte le mura sono
colorate questo breve filmato si vede
tutto quello che c'era prima e lo vedete
in bianco e nero e poi si vede il dopo e
lo vedete colorato la differenza dei
luoghi è forse quella più facile da
rendere no in questo video era difficile
far vedere un prima e un dopo di un di
un bambino di un ragazzo di una mamma
però è emblematica e rispetti
assolutamente quella che è la la cura e
quelli che sono gli effetti della cura e
quindi il primo del dopo che oggi
vediamo nel grigio e nel colore delle
case in realtà noi lo vediamo tutti i
giorni nelle storie di questi ragazzi
degli occhi nei sorrisi che finalmente
fioriscono vedete lo sport perché
quest'anno abbiamo iniziato anche a fare
piscina si chiama terramaini abbiamo
preso una una serie di corsi e per per
farvi notare la cosa incredibile che
abbiamo scoperto che tanti di questi
bambini una mano anche visto il mare ma
siamo in sardegna però in molti non
erano neanche andati al mare
facciamo musica facciamo tanta musica la
facciamo in maniera integrata diciamo
cioè mettendo chissà cantare che sa
suonare vicino a chi magari ha delle
difficoltà e quindi l'ultimo dei suoi
problemi
almeno fino a quando non ha incontrato
noi era cantare oggi ci pure forma di
cantare perché lo mettiamo su un palco
gli accendiamo le luci avete visto
abbiamo fatto un piccolo teatro dove
questi ragazzi si divertono a calcare le
scene ea provare a fare spettacoli
abbiamo voluto anche ospitare questi
sono i ragazzi di codice segreto che
diciamo affetto chi vive una situazione
di diversità in questo caso sono ragazzi
con disabilità psichica e loro sono
insieme a noi sul palco sono insieme ai
ragazzi delle comunità del territorio
questo è un territorio molto molto
particolare noi siamo andati nei palazzi
anche questi palazzi grigi dicevo ma
perché non ricoloriamo facciamo qualcosa
di diverso cambiamo un po ma siete matti
ma abbiamo cambiati adesso se passate
per via san passate per via trecenta per
le zone di santa teresa di pieri
iniziate a vedere questi palazzi che che
si stanno moltiplicando ea noi hanno
preso colore e le persone dentro
partecipano questo progetto perché sono
loro poi a scegliere insieme a noi
quello che viene disegnato sui palazzi i
colori e con gli artisti decidono e
stanno facendo la differenza questa è la
scuola una scuola abbandonata che sta
sempre là davanti all'ex me e avete
visto come era prima e come oggi anche
qui ci dicevano ma siete matti ma volete
la luna eccola qua insomma dall'alto fa
una certa impressione non vedere quello
che era prima e quello che sta
diventando oggi questo quartiere perché
le periferie poi se vogliamo possono
diventare luoghi dove è bello vivere
importante non dimenticarsene non
fermarsi di fronte agli ostacoli questi
sono i buoni e cattivi prima parlavo del
dopo così come è prevalentemente il
primo è la prevenzione anche se dicevo
rappresenta anche un po di
accompagnamento verso l'autonomia
sicuramente nel dopo i buoni e cattivi
sono i campioni del del settore
dell'ambito chi sono sono tutti i nostri
ragazzi ragazzi delle comunità che hanno
fatto una cooperativa e hanno iniziato a
lavorare insieme una decina d'anni fa
anche qui ci davano un po dei martiri ed
e visionari ma ci abbiamo provato
abbiamo fatto un ristorante e questo
ristorante ha vinto un po tutti i premi
che si possono vincere
michelin gambero rosso slow food super
recensito e riconosciuto che oramai come
uno dei locali d'eccellenza del
territorio
non contenti abbiamo aperto delle camere
dove soprattutto le mamme perché in
tutti questi anni non abbiamo trovato un
ragazzo un maschio che fosse in grado di
mettere a posto i letti e sistemare le
camere e soprattutto le mamme che sono
poi donne vittime di violenza sono le
mamme che hanno vissuto nelle nostre
comunità gestiscono la parte diciamo
ricettiva la parte turistica
oggi ci sono le camere ci sono gli
appartamenti e in queste camere e in
questi appartamenti lavora l'altra parte
della cooperativa quella femminile che
ha ingerito una con una cooperativa che
in realtà era un po maschio è un po dura
un po
un po anche antipatica non nasceva
questa è la canzone
ricordate probalmente la canzone di
vasco rossi nasce dai buoni e cattivi di
vasco rossi cantata nel carcere minorile
e la cooperativa era fatta dai ragazzi
del carcere che nel momento in cui è
entrata la prima donna sono entrati i
primi ragazzi con storie diverse quelle
di comunità e storie che al di là della
comunità comunque non erano quelli del
penale ha cambiato volto si è
ingentilito e ha trovato un percorso
il video non va avanti ma vi avrebbe
fatto gli avrebbe mostrato qualche
immagine del circolo a monte urpinu oggi
i buoni e cattivi hanno preso e hanno
creato una nuova realtà imprenditoriale
hanno aperto il bar o meglio hanno
riaperto un bar una pizzeria e
ristorante
oggi sono quasi 50 lavorano producono il
loro stipendio
sono un po una piccola eccellenza ma
soprattutto sono felici hanno creato una
una strada verso un futuro diverso sono
andati oltre loro per primi a loro più
di chiunque altro di noi probabilmente
stanno pensando forse lo avete già visto
qualche piccolo esperimento dal prossimo
anno di sperimentare anche di fare la
differenza al teatro lirico di cagliari
dove anche lì andremo a cercare una una
modalità diversa di presentare le cose
allora la diversità è il tentativo di
andare oltre è un po in tutte le cose
che ti ho raccontato
stasera la diciamo la caratteristica
comune è così come raccontava nelle
comunità così come dicevo delle comunità
quella di provare a fare qualcosa di
diverso migliori imparando da chi prima
di noi ha fatto andando in giro con una
oggi la chiamo parolaccia insomma era un
modo che si usava quando quando facevo
il manager quando facevo l'imprenditore
nelle realtà in cui ho avuto la fortuna
di lavorare
il benchmark in non andare in giro a
vedere chi sono i più bravi che sono i
migliori impari da loro e poi magari
cerchi di metterci qualcosa di tuo è
qualcosa di ancora ancora più avanti
questo facendolo nel settore dove è
fondamentale avere il cuore è
fondamentale gestire con la passione con
l'amore ma è altrettanto importante
anche cercare l'efficienza perché è
fondamentale il rispetto delle risorse
laddove le risorse sono risorse non solo
quelle del pubblico
secondo le vecchie logiche
dell'assistenzialismo ma magari quelli
degli amici quelle delle aziende che
credono in te vogliono contribuire e
darti una mano e quindi bilanci
trasparenti efficienza
nell'organizzazione ricerca anche di
tutti quanti quei metodi che nelle
aziende vengono utilizzati per il
profitto giustamente ma perché non
utilizzarli anche nel sociale per fare
sì che con le stesse risorse si riesca
ad ottenere di più quindi il mio il mio
invito è il tentativo più che un invito
sarebbe forse immodesto parlare in
questi termini a voi ma il mio tentativo
innanzitutto per me stesso è quello di
continuare a fare cose che siano nuove
diverse ma soprattutto pensate per
coloro che che ne hanno bisogno per per
coloro che poi sono i beneficiari che se
l'è godono e che ne approfittano ma
facendolo con l'aiuto di tutti e in una
modalità che è diversa rispetto a quella
dell'assistenza che c'era fino
qualche anno fa e che ancora oggi in
tante parti d'italia esiste cercando una
sostenibilità cercando qualcosa che oggi
c'è e domani rimane grazie
[Applauso]